- So I'm John Geanakoplos,
the chair of Hellenic studies department,
and a professor in economics,
and I'd like to welcome you all here.
I'm so glad to see so many of you,
so glad to see a previous
chair, Staffis Khalivas,
back from Oxford, here to
join us for these talks.
These lectures bring to Yale every year,
this is the 15th one of them,
distinguished scholars in the humanities,
or the social sciences,
or a public figure,
or an artist, or somebody of
an international reputation.
Yannis is all of those.
And as you probably know, the
Stavros Niarchos Foundation
has been the primary
sponsor of these lectures
since the program had its beginnings.
In fact, the Niarchos Foundation founded
the Hellenic Studies program,
as a pilot program, in 2001.
And then in 2007, it established
it as a permanent program.
And the Niarchos Foundation has therefore
created Hellenic Studies in Yale,
but that's not all it does.
It's worked all over the
campus to provide activities
in the School of Art, the Peabody Museum,
the Center for
Globalization, all over Yale.
But not just all over
Yale, all over the country.
So this is the Niarchos Foundation
that opened up recently in Athens,
spectacular building that
you've probably been to.
This is, in the center here, is the,
well that's the outgoing President
of the Yale Undergraduate
Greek Students Association, Daphne Martin.
And she's there with three of her friends,
the four of them from Yale,
went to Sparta to help
sponsor the rebuilding
of the archeological museum,
and to give tours of the
current archeological museum.
And I happened to be there at the time
and I read about them in the newspaper
and I rushed over to get a tour.
It was quite wonderful.
And I brought along my cousin, Anser,
whom you see on the side here.
(laughing)
Who turned out to be a rap singer
and possibly the second most
famous rap singer in Greece.
But anyway, he's also
a charging accomplice.
So what happened?
While I was there, of course,
I visited all my relatives,
in a little town called Theologos,
and here are some of them.
There are more of them.
So the Niarchos Foundation, turns out,
does a lot in Athens, in Sparta,
because Niarchos himself comes from a town
in Laconia called Vamvakou.
And so, for example,
the Niarchos Foundation
is building a hospital in Sparta,
designed by Renzo Piano.
And, most interesting to
me, the foundation decided
that there are not
enough young people left
in these beautiful villages.
The people are aging and the young people
are moving out of the villages,
and they're paying them
now for grade schoolers
from Athens to visit
Vamvakou during the summer
and see what it's like,
see what the culture of
the villages were like.
And also bring a little life
and energy to the villages.
Here is Vamvakou, you see what
a beautiful village it is.
And the long term
residents are under 20 now.
I mean, a disappearing village.
So of course Vamvakou
is not the only village
in the hills above Sparta,
where the people left
are a little bit old.
You can imagine Theologos being
part of the program shortly.
Well it turns out that Vamvakou
was only 30 kilometers from Theologos,
and I'm related to the Niarchos,
as I found out this summer.
So, Anser, who you saw before,
my grandfather's nephew
was Anser's grandfather,
married Anser's grandmother,
the Sarantopoulos family,
who was a second cousin
to Stavros Niarchos.
You know, the more I talk to my family,
I realize we're related to the Niarchos,
I didn't realize that.
Actually, my family might
have been doing better
than the Niarchos center.
So it turns out that my grandfather,
my grandmother, was the richest girl
and this is the house she grew up in
in the late 1800s, she was
born in the late 1800s.
It's now military center of Sparta.
But if you've been to Sparta,
you'll know there are not
many houses like that.
That's where my grandmother
would have lived.
So, my grandfather left
Theologos at the age of 12
in 1892, by himself, and came to America,
and built a candy factory.
And this is the candy
factory on Lake Hennepin
in Minneapolis, the first
Greek in Minneapolis.
You can see the Geanakoplos name.
There it is blown up a little
bit, the Geanakoplos name.
And, thank you, recently,
it's been remodeled.
(laughing)
It's now part of Calhoun Square
and the singer for
Minneapolis, known as Prince,
wrote a song about Calhoun Square,
my grandfather's candy factory.
So, I ask you, no.
(laughing)
So, today, we're very lucky
that the article's lecturer
is Yannis Stournaras.
He is a man, as I said at the
beginning, who's done it all.
He combines all the desirable qualities
of the article speaker.
He's an undergraduate at
the University of Athens.
He got his Masters at
Oxford, his PhD at Oxford,
in Economic Theory and Policy.
He became a Lecturer and Research fellow
at St. Catherine's College in Oxford.
Then he came back to Green
and was a Special Advisor
to the Ministry of Finance
at the Bank of Greece,
a Professor at the
University of Athens in 1989.
I decided I wanted a little
more detail about this.
So, one of my partners in a
business I run on the side,
his sister, Vicky Nicopoulos,
went to grade school
with Yannis and she said,
he was quick witted and very smart,
at least between the ages of 11 and 14,
when we took a tutorial
together in English.
And he had curly, reddish-blonde hair.
(laughing)
So, but Yannis after than became Chairman
of the Council of Economic
Advisers from 1994 to 2000,
in a crucial time for Greece
when they joined the EU.
So, just before the
European Monetary Union,
he became President and
CEO of Emporiki Bank,
the Vice Chair of the
Association of Greek Banks,
the Minister of Finance in 2012 to 2014
and the Governor of the Bank of Greece.
Now, not only does he do all these things,
he's also a mesmerizing speaker.
When I was there in 2013,
I was in So-union and there
was a talk in the moonlight
at the Temple of Poseidon that Yannis gave
and I was trying to remember
if the mythological theme
that he carried throughout
this whole talk.
I'm afraid I have forgotten it though.
But it was a beautiful speech.
So, let me say, again, how glad I am
to welcome all of you here
to meet article lecturers
and especially how glad I am
to welcome Yannis Stournaras,
even though this isn't quite
the Temple of Poseidon,
it's the Yale University, welcome Yannis.
(applause)
- Thank you, thank you, John.
I think, if I remember well,
I must have told you an
anecdote about Delphi
if I remember well, it
was because at that time,
at that time, there was a
controversy at which university
was better, Oxford or Cambridge?
So, the legation of both universities,
they went to Delphi to ask the Oracle.
So they asked the Oracle.
The Oracle using all the usual stuff.
She took hours and hours.
And then, at the end she turned them
and said, "What is Cambridge?"
(laughing)
Well, it's a really great
honor for me to be invited
to deliver the annual Stavros
Niarchos Foundation lecture.
The Hellenic Studies Program
at the Yale Macmillan Center
does an excellent job.
I had the opportunity to visit
some of the rooms here and
some of the colleagues.
In studying and promoting
contemporary Greek culture and history.
So in my talk today, I will first present
the lessons to be drawn
from the Greek crisis.
By the way, the title of this speech
will be "Greece in Europe:
The Reasons for Optimism".
So I will then discuss the
progress made in recent years
and the outlook for the Greek economy,
and highlight the crisis legacies
and the challenges that lie ahead,
both for Greece and Euro zone.
Finally, I will put forward
some policy proposals
for addressing these challenges,
both for Greece and the Euro area.
From 2000 to 2007, Greece experienced
benign macroeconommic conditions
characterized by high rates of GDP growth,
well above the Euro area average,
relatively stable
consumer price inflation,
and a gradually decreasing
unemployment rate.
The expanision was driven
mainly by rapid credit growth
and low borrowing costs following
financial liberalization
and Greece's entry into EMU in 2001.
The mastrate criteria for joining
Economic and Monetary Union were
based solely on nominal
conversions and therefore,
failed to incentivize
the structural reforms
in the product and labor markets.
And the functioning of the public sector
needed to enhance real conversions,
raise potential growth, and safe guard
the system ability of public finances.
On the contrary, employer and employee,
there as groups, opposed the reforms
that would have increased competitiveness.
Also, Greece's GDP per capita increased
during the boom period approaching
the European Union average.
The institutional GAP relatively
to the Euro area did not narrow.
Thus Greece continued to lag significantly
behind its Euro area partners
in various indicators
of governance and
structural competitiveness.
The sub deterioration of the fiscal
and macroeconomic
environment in 2008 and 2009
and the subsequent
downgrades of sovereign debt
and rising sovereign spreads
cut off the Greek sovereign
and banks from international
capital and money markets.
Substantial deposit withdrawals
and extremely tied legal conditions
put strain on the
banking sector and EUIMF,
Finance Economic Adjustment
Program, was initiated in 2010,
aiming to correct these imbalances.
The crisis has taken a heavy toll
on output, incomes, and the world.
Between 2008 and 2016,
Greece lost over one-fourth
of it's GDP at constant prices
and the unemployment rate
rose by nearly 16 percentage points.
Furthermore, GDP per
capita and purchasing power
of parity declined to 67.4%
of the EU average in 2018,
down from 93.3% in 2008.
To this, one must add the large increase
of non performing loans,
that is the NPL ratio
to about 50% of the total.
The large brain drain and
massive underinvestment
with an immeasurable economic
and social consequences.
The slide of the GDP growth
rate into negative territory
raised the debt to GDP ratio
to unsustainable levels,
despite the fiscal
consolidation and caused
their servicing problems for
high schools and businesses.
This was the main but
not the exclusive reason
why non performing
loans rose dramatically,
weakening bank's acid quality,
thus making difficult for banks
to finance the real economy.
It took no less than eight years,
three economic adjustment programs,
major debt restructuring, and three rounds
of bank recapitalization to
resolve the Greek crisis.
The length and depth of the Greek crisis
can be explained by seven factors.
First, the size and speed
of fiscal consolidation
were unprecedented.
This is primarily hard to do with the fact
that the initial fiscal
and accelerating balances
were much higher in Greece than
in other member states
on the financial stretch.
In addition, emphasis has,
on average, been placed
over the three adjustment
programs, more on tax hikes,
rather than on expenditure cuts,
growth and housing reforms,
and privatizations.
Second, the fiscal
multipliers turned out to be
higher than initially anticipated.
And the economy was soon caught
in a viscous circle of
hostility and recession.
Third, the second state
of structural reforms
led to real wages declining
more than initially expected,
exacerbating the recession.
In other words, the reform effort focused
much more on the labor market
than on the goods and services markets.
Hence, nominal wages declined faster
and more strongly than prices.
Households experienced a massive drop
in purchasing power, which in turn,
constrained personal consumption
and deepened the recession.
Fourth, the non performing loans problem
proved very difficult to manage.
Mainly the result of economic contraction,
it as further exacerbated
by legislative changes,
such as the blanket mediatorial
on primary residence auctions
and the abuse of foreclosure protection,
as well as several other legal
and judicial impediments.
With the benefit of hindsight,
it could be said that
a more dynamic response
during the first years of the crisis,
implementing the necessary
legislative change much earlier,
and introducing a systemic
solution by a centralized,
acid ]] for non performing
loans as other members
said hadam, could have reduced
the problem we face today.
Fifth, certain reforms fell behind
their Greek time schedule on
account of a number of factors,
including insufficient ownership
of the necessary reforms,
population rhetoric, political rivalry,
and the resistance of various
vested interests to reform.
This had serious consequences.
The signing of a third
economic adjustment program,
the introduction of
capital controls mainly
to stem the outflow of bank deposits,
and other bank recapitalization rounds.
In two years of economic stagnation.
Sixth, political deliberations
in the Euro area also played their part
in delaying the recovery
of the Greek economy.
The Euro group decision of November 2012
to grant further debt relief was put off
for a number of years and was
only implemented in June 2018.
This undermines the growth prospects
of the Greek economy and
prolonged the crashes.
Had this form of debt relief been given
at the beginning of the first
economic adjustment program,
alongside the implementation
of ambitious growth
and housing structural reform
and the national management company
to deal with the problem
of non performing loans,
it would have had a more
positive impact on the economy,
possibly limiting output
and employment losses.
Seventh, when the Greek crisis broke out.
The Economic and Monetary Union lacked
the tools to prevent
or contain the crisis.
The stability and growth
part failed to control
the buildup of public debt
in the big crisis period.
There was insufficient monetary
and control over macroeconomic
imbalances such as
the evolution of the current
account and private debt.
The sovereign bank, Dumloop,
amplified the financial
crisis in the recession.
Euro area crisis management
and the resolution tools
were poor or even nonexistent on account
of highly exaggerated
concerns about moral hazard.
And due to the lack of an
appropriate institutional setting,
there was no provisional for risk sharing
in the initial EMU architecture.
It was this business response,
especially after mid-2012,
which provided the time required
for Euro area governments
to take the actions necessary to safegaurd
the stability of the financial system
and strengthen Economic
and Monetary Union.
Despite the missteps, the
occasional backsliding and delays,
significant progress has been made
since the beginning of the
sovereign debt crisis in 2010.
The implementation of
economic adjustment programs
has eliminated the root
causes of the Greek crisis.
More specifically, the
achieved fiscal adjustment
was unprecedented,
turning a primary deficit
of 10% of GDP in 2009
into a primary surplus
of 4.3% of GDP in 2018.
The primary surplus in 2018 exceeded
the program target for
the fourth year in a row.
The current account
deficit has been reduced
by 12 percentage points of GDP
since the beginning of the crisis.
Labor cost competitiveness has been
fully restored and price competitiveness
has recorded substantial gains since 2009.
A bold program of structural
reforms was implemented,
covering such areas as the pension
and healthcare systems,
goods and services markets,
the business environment, the tax system,
the budgeted reform work, and
public sector transparency.
The banking system has been restructured.
Today, only four systemic banks control
over 95% of the market, as
more than 10 other banks
were merged or liquidated.
The role of the Bank of Greece was pivotal
in the restructuring and recapitalization
of the banking system, the enhancement
of it's corporate governance,
and the provision of
liquidity all over Greece,
especially during the crisis years.
Today, bank's capital adequacy ratio stand
at rather satisfactory levels
and their long loss provisions
are sufficient to address
potential credit risks.
A number of important reforms
have been implemented,
aiming to provide the banks with an array
of tools for tackling the
problem of non performing loans,
including the strengthening
of the supervisory framework
by setting operational targets
for non performing loan reduction,
the creation of a secondary
non performing loan market,
and the removal of various legal,
judicial, and a new set of barriers
through the management
of non performing loans.
This action has started to bear fruit,
as shown by the continuous reduction
of the non performing loans stock
in line with the targets set.
Non performing loans amounted
to 75.4 billion Euros
at the end of June 2019
down by almost 32 billion
from the peak in March 2016.
However, the impel ratio remains
high at 43.6% in June 2019.
As a result of the reforms implemented
since the beginning of the crisis
and the effort of enterprises to make up
for declining domestic demand
by exporting to new markets,
openness has increased substantially
and the economy has started to rebalance
over trade double export-oriented sectors.
The sear of total exports in GDP increased
from 19% in 2009, to 36% in 2018.
Exports of goods and services,
excluding the sleeping sector,
have increased in real terms
by 60% since the draft in 2009,
outperforming Euro area
exports as a whole.
The volume of trade
double goods and services
in the economy increased cumulatively
between 2010 and 2017
by approximately 14%,
relative to non trade doubles
in terms of gross value added.
Following the stagnation of 2015 and 2016,
GDP growth returned to
positive territory in 2017,
for it grew by 1.5% and
peaked up to 1.9% in 2018.
Recent real GDP data pointed
to continue expansion in
the second quarter of 2019,
which about 1.9% year on year.
Thanks to the improved economic conditions
and the reforms implemented since 2010,
the unemployment rate, though still high,
fell the 16.9% in the
second quarter of 2019,
from 27.8% at the end of 2017.
Moving forward, the Bank of Greece expects
that economic activity will remain
on a positive growth trajectory,
expanding by 1.9% for
the whole year of 2019,
that is by 2.3% year on year
in the second semester
of the current year.
And double of 2% next year, in 2020.
The outlook is, of course,
subject to downside risks
related both to the external,
but also the domestic environment.
The global growth and trade slow down
due to imminent trade war
could affect export growth
more markedly, while the disorderly Brexit
drew political tensions and
the recent increasing prices
are further significant downside risks.
A possible set of corrections
in a global capital
and financial market
could increase the cost
and reduce the availability of funding,
particularly for the private sector.
There are also downside
risks on the fiscal front,
associated with ongoing
cultural leaks, on pension cuts,
which could weigh on their sustainability.
In addition, an exacerbation
of the refugee crisis could scare tourism.
However, there are also
domestic opportunities
relating to a rapid implementation
of structural reforms
in Greece and a reduction,
both direct and indirect,
of the primary surplus fiscal targets.
The fact that Greece still lags behind
it's piercing competitors
in almost all industries
of structural competitiveness,
is a huge opportunity
for a rapid catchup,
which should be exploited.
Despite the progress made so far,
major sought and medium
to long-term challenges
and crisis related legacies remain.
The main medium to long term
challenges are the following:
the high public debt, who sets
an ability of goals improves
significantly in the medium
term with a mesas adopted
by the Eurogroup 2012 to 2018,
created uncertainty about business ability
to service it's debt in the long-term.
In the medium term, there's no problem.
Over the next 10 years, we have
no debt servicing problems.
Raising the cost of borrowing
both from the public
and the private sector and
harboring growth prospects.
Greece's negative current account balance
and large negative net
international investment position.
The high long term unemployment rate,
which generates inequalities,
threatening social cohesion
and increases the risk
of human capital erosion.
The projected demographic
decline due to population aging,
but also outward migration, which excerpts
downward precedent potential
growth and puts at risk,
the long term system ability
of the pension system.
The slow digital
transformation of the economy,
based on the digital
economy and society index
of the European commission,
Greece for the year 2019
ranks 26th among the 28 EU
countries, which implies
a high risk of technological
lack and digital illiteracy.
The multiyear recession
has left an investment gap
and risks permanently impairing
the productive capacity
of the Greek economy
through a hysteresis effect.
In more detail, gross
fixed cut of formation
of current prices fell
from 26% of GDP in 2007
that is before the crisis,
to 11.1% of GDP in 2018.
The largest proportion of
this decline at the standout
of 15 percentage points,
is due to shrinking
the residential investment, which fell
from 10.8% of GDP in 2007
to 0.7% of GDP in 2018.
Fixed capital investment,
net of depreciation,
has been negative since 2011.
Specifically in 2018, net
fixed capital investment
amounted to roughly minus 8.8 billion
or minus 4.8% of nominal GDP.
Positive net investment is a prerequisite.
If a capital stock
invest a potential output
of the Greek economy are to increase,
estimates by the Bank of Greece indicate
that the net capital
stock of the Greek economy
at constant 2010 prices
decline by 67.4 billion euros
in the period 2010-2016 to
622.2 billion euros in 2016.
In order to raise the net capital stock
over the next decade to pre-crisis levels,
growth fixed capital
formation at constant prices
needs to increase by about 10% a year.
However, excluding the
residential investment,
which accounts for about
50% of the capital stock,
gross fixed capital
formation at constant prices
needs to increase by
about 5% per year by 2029,
that is for the next decade.
Also, a business investment
growth rate of 5%
per year over the next
decade is rather high.
It is deemed perceivable
for the Greek Economy Base
on Historical Experience so
long as suitable investment
in business mending policies are pursued.
Investments needed to
accelerate in order to bridge
the investment gap in a timely manner
and avoid the so-called hysteresis effect.
As recently pointed out by
the European Commission,
Greece needs additional
public and private investment
in transport, solid waste,
industrial sewage treatment,
water supply, infrastructure,
and energy network connectivity,
mainly between the islands
and mainland Greece,
in information and
communication technology, ICT,
and in innovation,
education, and training.
Many of the above investments would align
Greece's environmental protection startups
with those of the rest
of the European Union,
something particularly important
given the risks of climatic change.
Addressing the challenges
of climate change calls
for coordinated efforts.
Incidentally, the bank of Greece has been
playing an active role in this area
through it's Climate Change
Impact Studies Committee
and it's various
publications of the topic.
Moreover, the Bank of Greece participates
in the Central Banks
and Supervisors Network
for Greening the Financial System,
aiming to enhance the role
of the financial system
in managing climate and
environmental risks,
analyze the micro financial
impact of climate change,
and strengthen the global response
to the threat of climate change.
Apart from the medium
to long term challenges,
the Greek economy also
faces major challenges
in the immediate future,
which need to be dealt
with as a matter of urgency.
Greek government bonds have yet
to regain investment rate stages,
despite the substantial decline
in the yields after the
new government took office.
And the recent successful issuance
of a new seven-year Greek government bond
at the yield of 1.9% with
significant participation
from foreign institutional investors.
Recently, 10-year government
bond hits fell below 1.4%.
And what is even more important,
the corresponding spread
fell below 200 basis points.
Most fell below 190 basis points today.
It is estimated that
investment Greek statures
could cut further the
spread by 60 basis points.
The Greek economy continues to face
very tight fiscal and monetary conditions,
compared to all the other
member states of the Euro area,
which negatively affect
its growth prospects
and overall competitiveness.
Parameter surpluses in recent
years have been very large.
The high parameter surplus targets
and their systematic overachievement
in recent years through the curtailment
of public investment
spending and high taxes,
have dampened the growth
dynamics of the economy,
reduced the competitiveness
of Greek businesses,
created a disincentive to work and invest,
and caused tax fatigue,
leading to a contraction
of the tax base and an exhaustion
of tax bases and tax paying capacity.
The monetary policies given by the ACB
has undoubtedly benefited Greek
businesses and households,
but not to the extent that it would have
if Greek government
bonds had been eligible
for the acid purchase program, the APP.
It is not eligible because we
don't have still investment
rates or we don't have a
precautionary credit line.
The fact that all the
other member states enjoy
much more favorable financial conditions
for their businesses has an
undoubtedly negative impact
on Greece's overall competitiveness.
The highest stock of non
performing loans impairs
bank's lending capacity and
increases lending costs.
This is yet another reason on top
of the previous one just mentioned,
why Greek businesses continue
to face higher financing costs
than their European counterparts
which undermine their
competitive position.
Despite the significant
drop in unit labor costs,
following the wide range of reforms
that were implemented in recent years.
It is indicative that according
to the most recently available data,
the average bank lending
rate for businesses
in Greece is still slightly below 5%,
compared to slightly
above 2% in the Euro area.
Up to now, the business environment
had not been considered
investment friendly
and in fact, discouraged investment.
Non-price competitiveness,
so-called structural competitiveness,
is very low compared to
Greece's EU partners.
This is mainly due to high tax rates,
weak public sector efficiency,
and delays in court
proceedings and rulings.
Here are some numbers.
According to the World
Economic Forum in October 2018,
Greece ranked 103rd out of 140 countries
in check in balances, which
refers to budget transparency,
judicial independence,
efficiency of legal framework,
and challenging regulations
and freedom of the press.
115th in public sector
performance, which is first.
To the man, who got in my relations.
Efficiency of legal framework
in settling disputes,
in participation index future
orientation of government.
119th in property rights protection,
which refers to property rights,
intellectual property protection
and quality of legal administration.
And 119th again, as
regards to the strength
of auditing and reporting standards.
According to the world banks
of doing business reports for 2019,
Greece ranks 132nd out of 190 countries
in terms of enforcing contracts.
Specifically, it takes
1,580 days for a case
to be heard by the competent
court of first instance
and for the ruling to be enforced,
compared to only 582 days in
the EUCD high-income economies.
And resolving insolvency takes 3.5 years
compared to 1.7 years in the
EUCD high-income economies.
Thus, the recovery rate
is 33.2% in Greece.
It gained 70% in the EUCD
high-income economies.
The reform's agenda of
the new Greek government
elected last July is viewed positively
by the international financial markets,
as indicated by the rapid decline
in Greek government bond
yields, which as I already said,
currently stand at below 1.4%.
The government is swiftly implementing
it's planned investment
growth strengthening polices,
which involve lowering business taxes
and placing more emphasis on
the reform and privatizations.
As a means to address short
and long-term challenges
and to reign force credibility
of economic policy.
Meanwhile, the substantial improvement
in positive execution, according
to recently published
Bank of Greece caste data,
between June and August 2019, indicate
that the primary surplus fiscal
target for 2019 will be met.
This should support the efforts
of the Greek government
to achieve and upgrade
of investment bonds, to
investment rate stages
by international
accrediting organizations.
Should this happen, Greek bonds
will then be allowed to participate
in recently enhanced
acid purchase program.
And therefore to reach
substantial benefits
in terms of lower borrowing
costs for the Greek economy.
If you remember, I said that this will cut
about 60 basis points for our
borrowing cost of average.
The recent economic policies should follow
a three-pronged approach aimed at, first,
achieving the agreed fiscal targets.
Second, drastically reducing
non performing loans.
And third, stepping up the pace
of structural reform privatizations.
The fact that the new
government immediately
announced that it will respect the agreed
fiscal target is a welcome development.
At the same time, in line
with what the bank of Greece
has repeatedly stressed in recent years,
the government is negotiating
both direct and indirect
of the primary surplus
target with institutions.
A lower, more realistic
primary surplus target
compared to the current one
of 3.5% GDP through 2022.
If combined with more
reform privatizations,
would probably imply lower
rather than higher public debt.
This is so because with a
public debt to GDP ratio
of 180% of GDP, a one percentage
point higher growth rate,
which is likely to materialize
if the lower primary surplus target
is received through lower
taxes and social contributions,
combined with more privatization
and structural reforms.
Or 100 basis points lower borrowing costs
which is already materialized related
to the European Commission's
base line scenario.
For those of you that you don't remember,
the base line scenario of
the European Commission
assumes an average 10-year
bond interest rate of 4.9%.
Right now it is less than 1.4%,
so that's a very big difference.
So, this is 1.8 times more effective
in reducing the debt ratio rather than
an additional GDP percentage
points over primary surplus.
The fact that government
borrowing costs today
are much lower than under
the base line scenario
of the European Commission's
debts and ability analysis,
provides leeway for
easing the fiscal targets
without compromising debt sustainability.
Moreover, the stability
and growth part allows
for fiscal flexibility,
so long as additional
reforms increase potential growth.
In a nutshell, there appear
to be sufficient grounds
for lowering the primary
surplus targets and harbor
on for a compromise solution.
In such a solution, primary surpluses
could be lowered in exchange
for an acceleration of reforms.
The outcome will be a win-win situation,
both for Greece and for it's EU partners
given that Greece will
be able to return faster
to a high growth path that
safeguards fiscal sustainability
and the repayment of bailout funds.
Downside risks relating
to external factors also
justify a reduction of the
primary surplus fiscal target.
Priority must continue to be given
to reducing the highest stock
of non performing loans,
which impairs bank profitability
and lending capacity
and delays the recovery of
investment and economic activity.
As I mentioned before, the ratio of NPLs
to total loans remains very
high, 43.6% in June 2019.
According to operational targets
for repair and reduction,
the aim is to bring the
NPL ratio down to 35%
by end of 2019 and to
below 20% by end 2021.
Overall, despite the
progress in this regard,
the pace of NPL reduction
has not been fast enough
to bring the Greek NPL ratio close
to the European average
of 3.1% as of March 2019.
The activation of a
truly systemic solution
to the end period reduction would resemble
an acid management
company, would alongside
the bank's own efforts
be key for cleaning up
the balance sheets of
banks for bank lending
to increase and for
investments to recover.
After all, similar solutions
have been implemented
in almost all member states
under financial stress.
Foreign direct investment
is also necessary
as domestic savings are insufficient
to match the investment
needed for high growth rates.
If Greece is to attract
foreign direct investment,
it must speed up privatizations
which mobilize additional
private investment,
promote private public
partnerships in various sectors,
and focus on removing major
disincentives such as red tape.
The lack of a clear and stable legislative
and regulatory framework,
an unpredictable tax system,
weaknesses in property rights protection,
limited access to financing
at high borrowing costs,
and delays in legal dispute resolution.
The lifting of capital controls
on September 1st is an important step
towards attracting
foreign direct investment.
In addition to helping
reduce the investment gap,
foreign direct investment
promotes closer trade links
with countries and companies
with state-of-the-art technologies
and facilitates participation
in global value chains.
This would increase openness and improve
both the quantity and quality
of Greek exported products.
Greater emphasis must also be placed
on improving public sector efficiency
through the modernization and utilization
of public administration
and state-owned enterprises
with a redesigning of
procedures and responsibilities,
and the valuation and development
of staff capacities and infrastructures.
Legal certainty and clarity
and a stable legal framework
as well as a speedy
and reliable resolution
of legal disputes would be fundamental
to strengthening the rule of law,
improving the investment climate,
and accelerating economic growth.
Moreover, international experience assumed
that robust economic growth
is achieved especially
by countries with good government
and strong, independent institutions.
Finally, it is necessary to strengthen
the knowledge triangle that is education,
research, and innovation through policies
and reforms of promoter
sets, technology diffusion,
entrepreneurship, and foster closer ties
We do businesses, research
centers, and universities.
Strengthening the knowledge
triangle and information
and communication technologies would lead
to the digital
transformation of the economy
and increase in the stock of knowledge
and productive capital, with development
of outward-oriented
sectors and more generally,
to acknowledge economy and society.
Ladies and gentlemen, Greece
belongs to the Euro area.
It is directly affected by
it's economic and financial conditions.
Hence, Greece has a very strong interest
in promoting and supporting policies
that strengthen the Euro area economy.
Policymakers around the world have learned
the lessons from the Great Depression.
A financial system in distress
requires active central bank intervention.
Thus, when the need
arose and in the absence
of an appropriate policy
response by governments,
the European Center Bank
stepped in decisively
to restore market confidence,
contain the sovereign debt crisis,
and support the Euro area economy
by safeguarding price
and financial stability.
The European Center
Bank used the asset side
of it's balance sheet
as well as other tools
such as for good guidance,
in addition to it's standard
and nonstandard industry policies.
Given the success of these policies,
some of these instruments
will be paramountly
included in the new standard framework
as the effective load
bound will largely continue
to be a binding constraint
on the interest rate policy
in a low inflation, low
interest rate environment.
Indeed, earlier this month,
following subdued inflation,
a downward revision of inflation forecasts
and weakening Euro area
growth, the governing council
of the ACB decide to adopt
an even more accommodated
monetary policy with an even
lower deposit facility rate,
a new asset purchase
program, more favorable times
for TLTRO three and a
new forward guidance.
Euro area governments took a
number of necessary actions
to safeguard the stability
of the financial system
and to strengthen the EMU
after the Greek crisis.
Policy actions have focused
on addressing institutional weaknesses,
structural fragilities,
and excessive risk taking
that led to the sovereign debt crisis
and the negative feedback
look between sovereigns
and banks, which in turn,
undermined Euro area stability.
Other steps taken involved
not only more effective regulation,
but also higher capital
and liquidity buffers
for banks, early warning systems
and the development of
market protection tools
to increase resilience
to potential stocks.
The reaction of the Greek crisis,
as well as the crisis
in other member states
acted as a catalyst for key initiatives
such as the provision of
intergovernmental loans
to Greece, the establishment
of the European Financial
Stability Facility
and it's successor, the
European Stability Mechanism.
Other initiatives which stemmed
mainly from the world
banking crisis included
the creation of the banking union with
a single supervisor mechanism,
a single resolution mechanism,
and the yet to be created
European deposit insurance keep,
the introduction of stricter
rules on banking regulation
and supervision, as well
as the establishment
of the European Systemic Risk Board.
Finally, the European Commission proceeded
with the development of a more
appropriate market production tools
which allowed for greater
emphasis on identifying
and addressing system-wide risks,
the strengthening of the
stability and growth pact,
the initiation of the
macroeconomic imbalances procedure,
and the European semester.
As a result of the above initiatives,
all member states that had
received European Union
and IMF systems are
not back on their feet.
Macroeconomic imbalances
have been corrected
to a large extent and
growth has been fostered.
Economic expansion in the Euro area
as a whole continues on beat
at a slower pace and EU bonds
have become more resilient
to financial stocks
over the past two years as reflected
in the results of the European
Union-wide stress tests.
Moreover, for additional member states
who were admitted to EMU
during the crisis years.
However, despite the
progress achieved so far,
the Euro area faces
several challenges ahead.
The recovery of the Euro area
from the financial crisis lags
behind the recovery of
it's global competitors.
This reflects weak
productivity performance
and the lagging behind innovation
and digital technologies.
Population aging and climate
change raise serious concerns
about the long term outlook
for the Euro area economy.
Post crisis who have seen a halt
in financial integration which
weakens private risks
airing in the Euro area.
According to a recent IMF discussion note
and in accordance to what
has been said before,
businesses in Greece pay a
2.5% higher rate of interest
of the financial debt
than similar businesses
in the same industry in
France, for instance.
Moreover, for every one
percentage point drop
in national GDP growth, consumption drops
by .75 percentage points on average
in the Euro area compared to only
.18 percentage points on
average in the United States.
Economic convergence in
terms of real GDP per capita
among the 12 old Euro area
countries has stopped since 2010.
This continues to hold true
even if you keep Greece
out because of the crisis.
Only the new Euro area member states
have sold substantial convergence.
Divergence has widened also in terms of
unemployment rates and
income inequality indicators.
So, bold steps need to be taken
to strengthen the Euro area.
In the financial sector, it is a priority
to complete the banking union
by creating the European
deposit insurance keep.
The banking union will help
to create a better integrated,
more efficient, and well-capitalized
European banking sector.
Coupled with the completion
of the capital markets union,
a single rule book for
banks and capital markets,
convergence in taxation frameworks
in capital market supervision,
and in solvency procedures,
and with European union rules
allowing pension funds
and insurance companies
to participate in long-term
market investments,
it can be expected to
support the single market
and to fund investment and growth.
More developed and integrated capital
and banking markets will
reduce funding costs,
improve the financing of the real economy
by diversifying the sources
of financing and facilitate
private risk sharing
through the capital and credit sonnets.
For example, as recently
flagged by the IMF,
if Greece were to improve
it's insolvency practices
to basic class standards,
it could reduce it's business average
debt funding costs by
about 50 basis points.
More developed and integrated
capital and buying markets
will also support the international roll
of the Euro through the creation
of more integrated and
liquid capital markets.
However, we need to make sure
that the expansion of
the known banking sector
does not endanger financial stability.
Increased risk sharing is highly desirable
but we should not forget that
greater public risk sharing
is only possible with
less not more sovereignty.
Risks sharing whether in
the form of a safe asset,
a central fiscal establilization tool,
it founded to ensure against unemployment
or a truly European deposit insurance key
should proceed simultaneously
with risk reduction
such as the reduction
of non performing loans
or national digressions and supervisory
and resolution rules for banks.
It is only in this way
that we can transform
what is in effect today in the Euro area,
a noncooperative zero-sum game
into a cooperative win-win game.
In addition, in a monetary
union such as the Euro area,
the adjustment of current
accounting balances
should be as symmetric as possible.
Not only member states with
excessive current account
deficits, but also members
with excessive current account
surpluses should adjust.
Monetary policy alone cannot
stabilize the economy.
Fiscal policy should also be active
in those member states where fiscal space
exist and public debt remains sustainable.
In particular, the Euro area urgently
needs investment in new technologies
in order to catch up with it's
competitors and investment
necessary to face the
challenges of climate change.
Part of this investment will be public
or in the form of
private-public partnerships.
Moreover, Euro area member states
needed to step up structural
reform efforts in the labor
and product markets to
make them more flexible,
which is necessary in
a single currency area.
And boost productivity and to make
public finances more robust.
However, in learning from the
Greek crisis, the sequencing
of domestic tax ware
policies is very important.
For instance, goods and
services market flexibility
is best achieved before or simultaneously
with labor market flexibility.
Otherwise, large real wage reductions
might occur which are
unnecessary and undesirable
both from an economic
and a social perspective.
In the context of economic
policy coordination
and with a view to
fostering real convergence,
improvement should be made
in institutional quality
and good governance across
Euro area member states.
So, to conclude, despite
some missteps and delays
in the implementation
of the required reforms,
Greece has made notable progress
since the start of their crisis in 2010.
The implementation of
economic adjustment programs
has eliminated several
macroeconomic imbalances.
The economy is now
recovering and has started
to imbalance towards the
tradable export-oriented sectors.
The bank of Greece
expected economic activity
would remain on a positive
growth rate trajectory,
expanding by 1.9% in
2019 as I said before.
That is by 2.3% year on year
in the second semester of 2019.
And double of 2% in 2020.
The catching up effect
from a long depression
is projected to counterbalance
the negative effect of a
serious global slowdown.
However, significant challenges
in crisis legacies remain.
That is a high public debt ratio,
a high MPL ratio, a high
long term unemployment,
while the brain drain and
other investments weigh heavily
on the long-term growth potential.
In order to contain future risks
and address the remaining
challenges and crisis legacies,
the government should
implement it's reform agenda
as soon as possible.
Because there are clouds in
the international horizon.
Moreover, the continuation of reforms
is an obligation to which Greece
is bound in the context
of enhanced surveillance
as it will last a precondition
for the activation of the medium
term debt relief measures.
Increased policy credibility
through the implementation of reform.
The speeding up
privatizations and unblocking
already improved investment
plans like the Eleni Kon.
It will increase market confidence
in the growth prospects
for the Greek economy.
In acceleration of non
performing loan reduction
through the adoption of a
truly systemic solution will
improve financial conditions
for businesses and housework.
As well as confidence and it
will accelerate investment and GDP growth.
The conditions described of both
will facilitate Greek government bonds,
regaining investment grade stables,
thus paving the way to the
inclusion of bouncing this,
it means recently enhanced
asset purchase program.
This in turn, would further
lower borrowing costs
of the Greek economy,
thereby boosting growth
and improving debt sustainability.
So in such a benign scenario,
growth rate higher than
currently projected, above 3%,
could be achieved through
increased investment.
This is possible because
the output gap increase
will remain negative
for a number of years.
Last but not least, in order
to enhance real conversions
and strengthen the
international troll of the Euro,
we must take steps to deepen
Economic and Monetary Union.
The only realistic way forward
is to simultaneously promote risk sharing
and risk reduction measures,
to improve policy
coordination and to make sure
that economical imbalancing
operates symmetrically.
I am optimistic that this,
despite occasional failures
and backtracking, having survived an acute
and long economic crisis
once more in it's history,
and contrary to almost
all pessimistic forecasts,
has now a great opportunity
to close the institutional investment
and structural competitor's gap
will be experiencing
competitors and cuts up fast.
My optimism is not only based
on technocratic arguments
but also on historical ones.
Please allow me to conclude my speech
by quoting the historian Roderick Beaton
in his great book, "Greece: A
Biography of a Modern Nation".
This is actually the last
paragraph of the book
that I'm going to quote.
"200 years ago, during the 1820s Greeks
"were the pioneers who
first mapped out the root
"that would lead from the
old Europe of great empires
"to the Europe of nation
states that we know today.
"No one should take it for
granted that Greece and Greeks,
"in future, will always align
with the values, traditions,
"and politics that we tend to
lap together and call Western.
"Geography and, to some
extent, also history
"may pull the other
way but as they prepare
"to celebrate the 200th birthday
of the Greek nation state
"in 2021, Greeks can take
pride in an achievement
"that by it's very nature
and from very beginning,
"has been one, not through isolation,
"but in partnership every difficult
"step of the way with other Europeans.
"It could not be otherwise because Greece,
"however understood or misunderstood,
"has always been part of the
modern identity of Europe too."
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you again.
That was wonderful.
It wasn't much mythology in it,
but it was an intuitive course
and it reflected your career.
It was about so many
aspects of the economy,
covering such a wide ground.
So we have at least 20 minutes.
We can take a few minutes
and answer some questions
if anyone would like to ask them.
Hi, okay, there we go.
We have one already.
- [Man] Can you give some specifics
about what climate
change will do in Greece?
What affects will it have in Greece?
- With the reforms that have occurred?
- [Man] Well, or in the future.
- Well, really, due to the crisis
will have made the economy more flexible.
Labor market flexibility,
less product market and
services flexibility.
You will have improved the
workings of the tax system.
Greeks now pay taxes.
Although, still tax evasion--
- [John] He's asking about climate change.
- Oh, sorry, you said
about climate change only?
- [Man] Yes, what effects
will climate change have?
- The effects of the climate change
which you can see if you visit
the side of the bank of Greece,
you will have a very large study.
Greece being a Mediterranean country
will face serious problems here
in the cultural sector
and in the tourist sector.
That's why...
Sorry.
This is why we need to invest
heavily in climatic change.
But acting alone is not the solution.
We need a much more coordinated
solution as you know.
So, certain large countries
staying out doesn't help.
And if the problem is very
acute and it might already
have started to create
serious consequences.
The melting of ice in the Anarctic
has started already, I'm afraid.
So, we should have started yesterday.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you for your remarks.
You made significant emphasis
on questioning non performing loans.
In fact, you mentioned it many times.
43% of loans outstanding
are not performing,
is that correct?
- Yes.
Unfortunately.
- [Audience Member]
Isn't that the definition
of a bank that is dead on arrival?
It's a zombie.
In the United States I
think the account was,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but it was a loan that says,
"Hey, I shouldn't price this."
Anyway, savings and loans associations
had terrific amounts on
non performing loans.
Those had to be wiped away in order
for the economy to get over the crisis.
As the account was despite
of what I'm saying.
- Yes, it is true.
This the main legacy of the crisis.
It doesn't have to do with
problems with the banking system.
It decreased with the sovereign debt
that the crisis, which
has impacted on bonds.
The fact is that, in nominal terms,
non performing loans has the value,
the nominal value of non performing loans,
has fell insignificantly
from more than 100 billion,
to about 73 billion today.
But the problem is that
the ratio remains high
because if you reduce, if
you sell NPLs for instance.
If you securitize NPLs,
you reduce the numerator
but you reduce the denominator as well.
That's why in the bank a visual
can come out to the conclusion that along
with he strong efforts by the banks,
we also need a systemic solution
in the form of aa asset
management company.
The bank of Greece has
worked out a solution.
The government is about
to adopt a solution now,
which of course is not a
systemic one, but it helps.
We will hopefully be
approved by the economy
in the European Commission
in the next few weeks,
and then it will submit for approval,
the bank of Greece planning.
So these are the solutions
to talk about, that need
to be implemented alongside
the efforts of the banks.
Because despite these efforts,
the problem is so large as we described
that despite reduction in
the next three to four years,
the distance between
Greece and European peers,
in terms of erasures,
will remain very high.
This is why we need a systemic solution.
Not only the individual efforts of banks.
After all, many financially
distressed member states
have made use of this.
So like Harlem for instance
or Spain or even Cyprus.
- [Student] I wanna
follow up the question.
- John can you turn up the microphone?
- [John] The microphone?
Because the question
will not be videotaped
and our speaker may not
actually hear your opinions.
And so, if you have a
microphone, please use it.
- We have several microphones I think,
but anyway, we have one.
So I think many of you may
have had the same experience
I did visiting Greece a couple years go.
If course, as a foreigner it was okay,
but the local people couldn't
take money out of the banks,
more than a few Euros a week.
Because during capital controls
because everyone who was able
up until the point had moved
their money outside the banks.
And not 43% but 50% non performing
loans all over the world,
people were worrying and even expected
that the banking system was
going to completely collapse.
There you were, head
of the bank of Greece,
head of a system on the verge of collapse.
And now, it seems much better.
What did you do?
What happened?
How did it get better?
It seems so bad just two
years ago or three years ago,
how did you solve the problem?
How did Greece solve the problem?
- I think the main, the catalyst
was the return of confidence.
So, we stand to the outflow of deposits.
We recapitalize banks.
We consolidated the banking system.
As I said, now we have
only four systemic banks
and a number of smaller nonsystemic ones.
We used to have more than
20 before the crisis.
- [John] Confidence in what?
You restored confidence in what?
- Confidence in the financial system
and the fiscal system both.
That's extremely important.
- [John] How?
What made people think things
were gonna get better instead of worse?
What was the magic that you created?
- The fact that both government
and oppositions finally
discovered that there
was no other way out but to
follow the orthodox way of
reducing fiscal imbalances
and doing structural reforms.
So when this happened, things
started working more properly than before.
- Okay.
One more question to you.
- I would like to say that on the NPLs,
I have a question.
So when the sound importance of disposing
this number from loans, my question is,
when this is done, will this affect
the balance sheet of the banks?
The question is, who will take
the loss, the hit, that is?
Provisions are already taken and--
- Sorry, I can't, I can't.
- Provisions for this,
but that are already
taken is the question.
Or if not, who would take the
heat after this end result,
and if this will be reflected
on the balance sheet,
and if these banks will continue
to make these capital
adequacy rules, et cetera?
- Okay.
Well, provisions are about 50% of the NPLs
and another 50% is the
value of the collateral.
So actually, the so-called
Texas ratio is about right.
So the question is of how do we do it
to liquidate the collateral
to help banks solve a problem.
The capital adequacy ratio is
about the European Union average,
so we're not solved in
terms of tier one capital.
The main problem remains the
high ratio of NPLs so that's--
- When those are sold, it will be--
- The problem will be solved.
- No, when the NPLs are sold.
When the hedge funds, when
the management company,
will this affect the balance
sheet of the current banks?
Or this has already
been taken provision of?
Or it will be shown badly
on the balance sheet
and income statements of the banks,
will their financial
positioned be worsened
after these NPLs are sold?
That's the question.
- The balance sheet will improve a lot
if you reduce the value of NPLs.
It will be much better
according to the balance
sheet of the banks.
But also, let me take one small example.
Now banks set aside 2%
every year of the value
of the loans for provisions
so they reduce profit.
So profitability is being
affected dramatically
by these 2% reduction every year.
This is the cost of credit risk,
so imagine what will happen
when these will convert
to the European Union,
or their talks about 0.2, 0.3%.
So the profitability of
the banks will increase.
You can generate capital from
high-profitability and so
you can stop leveraging and
start letting go of the game.
Of course, gross lending
has started but net lending
remains still negative because
of the high impair problem.
- I just wanna put her
question in a different way.
Very often in these kinds of crisis,
the banks can pretend that their loans
are worth more than they really are,
and it's only when they're forced
to actually sell them
as the Greek government,
you are forcing the banks to sell them.
So one might have expected
that when they've got sold,
it would be revealed that they really were
worth much less than
the banks were saying.
But it seems not to be the case.
It seems, not for a many have been sold,
but they seem to be getting
sold at more or less,
the level that they were marked at.
Is that true?
That's her question.
Is that true, that they have been sold
at the level that they were valued?
- They are sold at market prices.
Still, market prices are
lower than the initial values.
- Not the initial values.
But the--
- Than the actual values.
But market price has improved now.
And also, the collateral improves
because of the higher
value of real estate.
So this is extremely important.
So, banks--
- Confidence has been
restored and the whole
economy is helping everything.
The collateral prices are going up.
The NPL values are going up.
- But that's exactly--
- And that's a miracle
that happened in the last two years.
- John, this is exactly why
we try to convince our peers
and partners that it is
imperative to allow us
a lower fiscal target in order
to improve the growth rate.
Because the growth rate
is like a global factor,
which will improve everything.
The bank's balance sheet,
the balance sheet of house,
courts, and companies.
So this is really the catalytic force.
- [John] I'm trying to
keep track of the question.
- [Gregory] Thank you very much.
You mentioned bank capital,
but in fact, a lot of bank
capital is funny money capital.
It's not real capital.
It's deferred tax credits.
And so I was wondering
if you could tell us
what is the expected,
what are the projections
for the effectively elimination
of this funding money
capital, and moving to
targets which are real money capital
which will provide a true
buffer for future losses?
Which, by the way, the funny money capital
makes the urgency of your
proposal even more good.
And if you don't mind
also, tell us in particular
if you can, about public power
corporation loans which are,
if not handled properly, will
revert to non performing.
For the Greek banks,
the exposure is mostly
with Greek banks and
European investment banks
as I understand, we're
guaranteed to the public
which also may have some effects.
So, I'd like to know what
steps are being taken
to ensure that these loans
will not be reclassified?
- For those of you that
you're not specialists,
we say analytics, we first capital
in the form of deferred tax claim,
which a claim of the
banks towards the state.
Why this claim has been created?
Because when the PSI
happened, banks had damages,
losses, which created tax claims.
Those future tax claims,
they are called deferred tax claims.
So, now, when a bank has
profits, it doesn't pay taxes.
If a bank has losses, then the state
will intervene with a capital increase.
This is very, very, the definition
of the deferred tax claim.
For the regulator, the deferred tax claim
is a perfect form of capital.
We do not consider it as
a lower quality capital.
It's a claim on the state
and the state will honor this claim.
Of course, we understand that
credit rating organizations,
they don't like this form of capital
and this is why the proposal
of the bank of Greece
tries at one stroke to
solve both problems,
the impair problem and the DTC problem.
That's why when I refer
to systemic solution,
I mostly refer to the
proposal of the bank of Greece
who solves at least half
of the impair problem
and at least half of the form of capital
that you mentioned, the DTC.
Now, hopefully when the
so-called acid protection scheme
is being approved by
the European Commission,
the Greek banks will make use of this
which is a positive step
in the right direction.
But it is not enough in my view.
We need a much more systemic solution
in the form of the bank
of Grrece proposal.
Now, the PPC.
The PPC is a serious problem,
but it has a solution.
If you think what happened to the PPC
over the previous years, it was a company
where it could not raise taxes.
Sorry, it could not raise tariffs.
A company that it could not collect debt.
A company that it could
not privatize it's assets.
So, the government will make use of
several of these instruments
to put the company back
into sustainability.
So it does need to write off debt.
It simply needs to do what,
I would say, a rational government
should do for a state electricity company.
But it has been done all over the world.
- [John] Yes, you with
the glasses and the suit.
- [Student] So I have
glasses and suit also.
(laughing)
- [John] All right, well, you're next.
- [Male Member] So thank you
for your remarks, Governor Stournaras.
During Greece's legislating counterparty,
is tilting on the verge of a recession by
market undilated metrics,
at least there were
on some type of looking forward.
So, will or how Greece's
economic recovery efforts
may be impacted by impossible asleep
in the typical recession in general?
And secondly, the question, I heard---
- [John] Let's take the one.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- So, yes, you have the right to generally
have two quarters of negative growth
so technically, it's in recession.
The reasons have to do with
the imminent trade war,
which has affected German's
exports to China in particular.
But also, there are some
specific factors related
to the carrying duster in Germany.
So it might or might not continue.
It has an impact on Greek exports.
So not a serious one.
The exports growth we
experienced in previous months
shows that it is resilient
despite the recession in Germany.
But the solution must come from
an activation of fiscal police in Germany.
Germany has a huge fiscal space.
Germany has a huge current account space.
It's not reasonable not
to use these spaces.
It can borrow, the German state
can borrow at negative interest rates.
So it can build it's
infrastructure by subsidizing,
by having a subsidy from the
financial markets, not a cost.
So this is why we strongly
urge Germany to take action
and expand it's infrastructural
and public investment.
- [Male Member] Will they listen?
(laughing)
- I think they are listening
and if I'm correct,
they will start spending
on climatic change.
I think this will be the first
public investment in Germany.
- [John] They could invest
in Greek infrastructure.
(laughing)
Okay, next question.
- This is not, Germany
can directly participate
in Greek investment
projects, for instance,
in the energy sector or they can do it
indirectly through the
European investment bank
by enhancing the capital of
the European investment bank.
And the European investment
bank can take action
and invest in Greece or in the
rest of the European south.
So there are many ways that Germany
can contribute to the
recovery of the Euro area.
The important thing is that
Germany, the Netherlands,
for instance, and one of
two other member states
of the Euro zone, they have
enough fiscal space that can
expand and be the locomotive
and stop a deeming recession.
Or it's a slowdown in the Euro area.
- [Gregory] Thank you very
much for, Governor Stournaras,
for a very informative talk.
- I'm very glad to see you here Greogory.
- [Gregory] I apologize.
I was a little late.
The traffic from New York is unbelievable.
- [John] Why don't you identify yourself?
- I'm the proud father
of a Yale student here.
My name's Gregory Prestagos
and I know Governor Stournaras
for many, many years.
So thank you for you informative talk
and thank you for your leadership during
these years of crisis because
all of us were outside.
We know how much wisdom and
guts it takes what you did.
I think the general sentiment is that,
the sentiment in Greece has changed,
it's huge of community.
We see a lot of things
happening very quickly.
I will say when I saw the strategical plan
of the government, I couldn't believe it
because I'm used to these
things at the corporate level
and I saw it at the government level,
but you refer to the clouds,
there are some clouds
and the question ended about Germany
and you talked about Brexit
and there's issues
generally about the slowdown
and the gap of the European
innovation and economy.
So what would be some
quick steps to increase
the resilience of this newly born
and very domestic prospect
that we've created on base?
What would you suggest as
some quick steps to take?
- I think the liberalization
of the legislation
governing foreign direct
investment is very important.
Then the liberalization
of the networks of
domestic markets in Greece
should continue, but I
think the most important,
the catalyst will be, for instance,
large user legislation to attract
foreign direct investment,
all the impediments to
following direct investment.
The revival of projects that
had stalled, they're important.
So, the international community
expects a new government
to do a number of quick
wins in the beginning.
But what I said, the three-pronged
strategy, first of all,
continued to respect fiscal
target, but at the same time,
negotiating a reduction of
the primary surplus target.
Second, a systemic solution
for non performing loans.
And third, of course, what we
said now, structural reform.
All those...
I would advise the new development
minister to do one thing,
to take the doing business
report of the Gold Bank
and see line by line, why we
were so low in the ranking.
And just correct all of these
impediments and be sure that
in a few months, there's
going to be a huge upgrade.
- [John] By the way, I
know yours was up too.
But I'm gonna stop for Yannis.
I know you.
(laughing)
- [Older Man] Thank
you very much for the--
- [John] No, it should be up.
(laughing)
- [Older Man] Thank you very
much for an interesting talk.
And you said that the
end state of net capital
is about 620 billion.
- Yes.
- So this implies a
capital over ratio of four.
So on the basis of this calculation,
we need 200 billion euro
investment to recover the loss.
How is that going to help what we want
and how will it impact?
- What I said is that in
order to be realistic,
we don't need to increase
investment by 10% a year.
If we give power to
this decile impressment
and just put emphasis only
on the industrial investment,
then you would need an
increase of 5% a year.
That should come mostly through--
- [Older Man] I just said the GDP.
- No, no, no 5% a year growth.
You need 5% growth a year in order
to restore the business capital.
We had a precrisis.
So we said that this is not impossible.
This is not impossible.
But of course, you need
both domestic investment
but mostly we need
foreign direct investment
for one simple reason.
Now, we save about 10%
of GDP and investment
is about 12% of GDP total investment.
In Greece, to double the investment ratio,
we cannot do it through boarding
because the current
account will explode again
as it did in the past.
So we need foreign direct investment
to cover this gap and this is why
the new government, very correctly,
has proved the attraction
of private direct investment
as a number one priority,
but that's the...
- [John] We have time for just--
- And for the domestic investment,
we need to reduce NPLs and reduce
the financing cost of companies
in order to make domestic
investment liable again.
- [John] Okay, we have two more questions.
Young lady, you're a
little in the view, but--
- And definitely Coastal's
got to ask for a,
Coastal or no?
Yeah.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Woman] You talked about
approaching foreign investment
but I had a rather specific question.
In terms of Greeks abroad that want
to open a bank account in Greece because--
- Sorry, I can't, can you--
- [Woman] Greeks abroad who
want to open a bank account
in Greece because domestic residents,
all they need is their tax returns
but there don't seem
to be peer regulations
for Greek citizens abroad for
what a bank has to ask for.
So is there a way to amend regulations
or clarify what a citizen
abroad would need?
Or would you just need their tax return
or something like that?
- If I understood well, you asked about
how can you open a bank account in Greece.
- [Woman] There don't seem
to be clear regulations.
Domestic citizens, there's
a clear set of regulations,
but for abroad and Greek citizens
there don't seem to be clear regulations
and I was wondering is that is
sort of what make
- Sorry, I cannot hear.
- [John] From my understanding,
peer regulations--
- [Woman] So if you're a
domestic Greek citizen,
there's clear regulations
for what you need
to go to a bank and do
whatever you need to do.
- [John] If you got to a bank in Greece?
- [Woman] In Greece.
- [John] And so if you're living abroad?
- [Woman] If you're living
abroad, there don't seem to be
clear regulations for Greeks abroad.
- [John] To go to what bank?
- [Woman] In Greece.
- [John] To go back to Greece?
- [Woman] Yeah, and open an
account locally or whatever.
But there aren't clear regulations
so I'm asking is there
a way to amend that, or?
- Greece is a member of
the European community
so it's banks follow the
same rules as those applied
in the European communities,
so there's a uniform.
There are uniform rules in the Euro area
which determines how
you open bank accounts.
Of course, there is regulations.
They are under money laundering
regulation which banks
take some separate caution
when you open a bank account.
But there is no difference.
We don't treat differently
citizens from other countries.
If I understood well your question.
- [John] Let's move to the last question.
It's a slightly more technical question.
We'll move to the last question.
- Thank you Governor Stournaras.
You helped us.
What I'm hearing is that there's
a need for foreign and domestic.
I'm hearing there's a
great need for confidence
in the Greek economy and
the financial structures
in order to generate
investment for domestic.
How well has grace made any progress
on the corruption perception index?
Last time I saw that, we were
greased with abysmally low
for a developed country
so that is one query.
Obviously, I think
addressing that would lead
to an upsurge in confidence.
And at this time a lighter note,
I went and told my friend
John that the pronunciation
of my grandmother's village is Vabakou.
(laughing)
Yes sir.
Thank you very much.
- That's why I said that...
The fact that we are so low
in all of these industries provides
an opportunity if the new
government acts quickly
to correct all these
let's say structural imbalances.
We'll see an upgrade very quickly.
I have quoted certain numbers
so that Greece is very,
very low in the ranking
in all these industries
of structural competitiveness, including
how quickly the judicial
system solves the difference
and how digitalized the economy is.
So we have a long way to go,
but there's also an opportunity here.
This is a problem but
also a big opportunity
because if we are so low in the ranking,
we can jump very high by
changing this quickly.
And there is no political cost in this.
We can implement it
very, very, very quickly.
So this is why am
optimistic and I say that
I'm an optimist about the
prospect of the Greek economy
because if we concentrate
on these other easy wins,
we can change the framework a lot.
- [John] And on this
note, thank you very much.
(applause)
(bright music)